[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend es ist eine eigentümliche
parallelität in deutschland hat der
deutsche bundestag heute das
abtreibungsrecht liberalisiert
insofern dass arztpraxen und kliniken
künftig darüber informieren dürfen dass
die schwangerschafts abbrüche vornehmen
und praktisch zeitgleich entscheidet der
oberste gerichtshof der usa das dort
bisher landesweit geltende liberale
recht auf abtreibung zu kippen damit
könnten jetzt die amerikanischen
bundesstaaten je nach politischer
gemengelagen schwangerschafts abbrüche
sogar gänzlich verbieten dass der
gerichtshof auf diese weise die zeit
zurückdreht liegt am politischen system
der usa
die entscheidenden richter hatte donald
trump platziert und nun wirken sie über
seine amtszeit hinaus
washington als 33 morgen 10 uhr 10 und
washington dc freudenschreie
champagner-dusche provokante
schadenfreude
[Applaus]
ihr habt verloren ihr hab verloren
verloren
verloren habe die demokratie so sieht
das die andere seite der oberste
gerichtshof in washington hat am
vormittag das fast 50 jahre alte
liberale bundesweite abtreibungsgesetz
gekippt das sei ein schlag gegen
selbstbestimmung und freiheit
ihr scheiß heuchler jetzt so als geht es
um babys aber das stimmt einfach nicht
der heuchler das sei der oberste
gerichtshof seit der amtszeit von trump
mehrheitlich konservativ besetzt die
begründen das kippen des gesetzes
folgendermaßen die verfassung gewährt
kein recht auf abtreibung die befugnis
zur regelung des
schwangerschaftsabbruchs wird an das
volk und seine gewählten vertreter
zurückgegeben und die sind bereits tätig
geworden in 13 bundesstaaten treten ab
jetzt vorbereitete gesetze die
abtreibung verbieten oder deutlich
einschränken in kraft ausnahmen für
schwangerschaften als folge von
vergewaltigung und inzest gibt es nicht
überall in 13 weiteren bundesstaaten
gibt es noch keine neue regelung es wird
aber von verboten und strengen
restriktionen ausgegangen bundesstaaten
wie new york oder kalifornien dagegen
haben das recht auf abtreibung
festgeschrieben in der begründung
außerdem eine empfehlung nämlich das
überdenken von weiteren urteilen etwa zu
verhütungsmitteln gleichgeschlechtlichen
beziehungen und der homo ehe für die
demokraten das urteil eine bedrohung des
rechtsstaats
diese entscheidung ist das ergebnis
jahrzehntelanger bewusster bemühungen
das gleichgewicht unseres rechts zu
steuern es ist die umsetzung einer
extremen ideologie und ein tragischer
fehler des obersten gerichts
doch ohne ausreichende mehrheit werden
die demokraten wohl wenig dagegen
unternehmen können so bleibt erstmal der
triumph des mannes der für sich in
anspruch nimmt das alles eingefädelt zu
haben diese und andere entscheidungen
die in letzter zeit verkündet wurden
waren nur möglich weil ich alles wie
versprochen gehalten habe einschließlich
der nominierung und bestätigung von drei
hoch angesehenen und starken
verfassungsrechtlern für den obersten
gerichtshof der vereinigten staaten es
war mir eine ehre dies zu tun
unterdessen geht der protest der
arbeiter die das neue urteil so nicht
hinnehmen wollen linke vereinigungen
drohten bereits mit einer nacht der wut
präsident biden mahnt dass gewalt keine
lösung sei die spaltung der gesellschaft
scheint immer größer zu werden
tja benjamin daniel ist für uns in
washington
man ahnt dass das hat politische folgen
dieses urteil
ja in der tat also man muss ja immer
vorsichtig sein finde ich mit wörtern
wie historisch wenn es um die einordnung
solche entscheidungen geht aber in
diesem fall kann man glaube ich wirklich
von historisch sprechen und zwar eine
historische entscheidung die das land
150 jahre zurückwirft um es mit den
worten des us-präsidenten zu sagen joe
biden hat sich ja vor ein paar stunden
geäußert und er hat gesagt das ist ein
trauriger tag sei dass es eine falsche
entscheidung sei ein trauriger tag für
dieses gericht und für dieses land denn
hier hat sich eine konservative
minderheit gegen den mehrheitswillen der
amerikanerinnen und amerikaner
durchgesetzt das wird mit sicherheit
dazu führen dass sich die fronten weiter
verhärten und dieses thema wird amerika
noch lange beschäftigen auch im hinblick
auf die zwischenwahlen im november und
ohne gesamt hatte das ganze hier haben
kunden genommen in gang gesetzt
ja in der tat das kann man wirklich
sagen er hat ja in seiner amtszeit drei
der amtierende neuen richterinnen und
richter am supreme court nominiert
allesamt erz konservativ und
selbstverständlich war schon damals klar
dass er extrem und auch nachhaltig die
großen linien der gesetzgebung in diesem
land damit prägen wird
er wirkt also das wirkt also weit über
seine amtszeit hinaus und seine
strategie der radikalisierung ja auch
der republikanischen partei
die scheint aufzugehen
und sie betrifft auch nicht nur die
höchsten stellen den zug rekord diese
radikalisierung die findet auf allen
ebenen statt und so wirkt wird ein thema
nach dem anderen zum kulturkampf erhoben
und für wahlen wahlkämpfer auch
instrumentalisiert und die folge ist
dass die gesellschaft sich nicht etwa in
einem heilungsprozess befindet was sich
ja viele millionen amerikanerinnen und
amerikaner sehr wünschen die folge ist
dass die gesellschaft immer weiter
auseinander driftet dankeschön für diese
einschätzung
das sind kriegen hunger als waffe
eingesetzt wird ist wahrlich nicht nur
den gegner zu belagern und auszuhungern
oder felder in brand zu setzen
und handelsstraßen zu blockieren all das
gehört praktisch seit menschengedenken
zum arsenal was putin allerdings im zuge
eines angriffskriegs veranstaltet hat
doch eine neue globale dimension dadurch
dass die ukraine als wichtiger
weizenexporteur weitgehend ausfällt und
auch russland nicht wie bisher
exportiert geraten andere weltregionen
in not vor allem auf dem afrikanischen
kontinent
das ist keine ungewollte nebenwirkungen
sondern hat system auf der
welternährungskonferenz heute in berlin
wurde über gegenstrategien beraten
andreas kühn ausrichtet
die russischen bomben treffen die häfen
der ukraine
die russischen bomben treffen die felder
der ukraine treffen ihre
getreidespeicher die russischen bomben
treffen die welt vor dem krieg hat die
ukraine jeden monat fünf millionen
tonnen getreide exportiert im ersten
kriegsmonaten gelangt nur 200.000 tonnen
heraus und mehr als zwei millionen
tonnen sind einfach nicht zu schaffen
das russische militär verwüstet
ukrainische farmen und silos es spielt
ukrainisches getreide und die ausrüstung
es zu ernten es blockiert die
ukrainischen helfen
es wäre so viel dafür so viele menschen
25 millionen tonnen getreide hängen auf
ukrainischen schiffen in den
schwarzmeerhafen fest während 900
millionen menschen nicht genug zu essen
haben während politiker aus aller welt
versuchen die schlimmste hungerkrise
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg noch zu
verhindern in berlin suchen am
nachmittag die vertreter von 40 staaten
auswege transportwege über lebenswege
für ganze familien ganze dörfer für eine
generation
deutschland beabsichtigt vor dem g7
gipfel so viele politiker wie möglich
aufzurütteln weil ein einziger sein
versprechen nicht hält präsident putin
hat schon vor einigen wochen zugesagt
den getreideexport aus der ukraine vor
allem über den seeweg zu ermöglichen
doch solche eine zusage ist nichts wert
wenn sie nicht eingehalten wird
präsident putin sitzt diese woche dann
eben als seine chef propagandisten etwas
erzählt dass sie einen witz nennt
der geht so wir setzen all unsere
hoffnung auf die hungersnot sobald der
hunger beginnt werden alle die
sanktionen stoppen und unsere freunde
sein wollen weil alle merken dass es
unmöglich ist nicht unser freund zu sein
es lacht niemand laut in sankt
petersburg putin kann auch leise
zufrieden sein in vielen ländern wird
seiner behauptung geglaubt dass nicht
russland und sein krieg verantwortlich
ist für den hunger sondern der westen
und dessen sanktionen den immer
krasseren lügen mit denen moskau
versucht täter und opfer zu vertauschen
setzen wir deswegen auch mit dieser
konferenz greifbare solidarität entgegen
bevor der erste getreidefrachter
ausläuft müssten die seeminen weg mit
denen die ukraine den hafen von odessa
schützt dafür müsste sie einem
russischen nicht angriffs versprechen
glauben getreide ist knapp aber
vertrauen noch knapper
und über diese probleme wollen wir mit
dem bundeslandwirtschaftsminister
sprechen mit dem ihren guten abend herr
ist demi moore nahm frau slomka haben
sie irgendeinen irgendein optimismus
dass man es schaffen wird aus dem hafen
von odessa noch schiffe herauszubekommen
oder sollte man diese idee vielleicht
langsam auch ad acta legen und sich auf
andere wäre konzentrieren
also jedenfalls eine ukraine traut
niemand wladimir putin und das kann ich
gut verstehen denn selbst wenn es jetzt
wie auch immer
schießereien geben würde und eine
waffenruhe geben würde selbst dann muss
man davon ausgehen platini putin ist
wladimir putin und er kann jederzeit
auch wieder die ukraine blockieren er
kann jederzeit wieder die ukraine
erpressen damit das heißt man muss sich
darauf einstellen die alternativ routen
sie nicht temporär so wir brauchen
dauerhafte alternativ routen zum
schwarzen meer ein problem ist auch dass
der hafen vermint ist und der ukraine
hat um sich zu schützen und dann müssten
sie die minen räumen und dann den russen
glauben dass sie das nicht ausnutzen
also fühle mich so ein bisschen das der
un-generalsekretär immer noch so
optimismus verbreitet bei dieser sache
ja also die ukraine beteiligt sich an
diesen verhandlungen aber so richtig
glauben kann niemand nach all den
gebrochenen worten von wladimir putin
das kann man der ukraine auch nicht
ernsthaft raten sich darauf einzulassen
von daher ist es umgekehrt unsere
aufgabe jetzt als weltgemeinschaft als
europäische union aber auch als bonus
pack deutschland dass wir mit den
nachbarländern mit ein anderer staaten
der ukraine gemeinsam und es danach um
schauen was die besten alternativrouten
werden um dauerhaft getreide aus der
ukraine abzutransportieren in meinem
gespräch das ich heute mit meinem
ukrainischen amtskollegen mit golasowski
hatte war klar die ukraine möchte
dauerhaften alternativen weg haben und
sie ist auch bereit zusagen zu machen
was die menge angeht so dass sich die
frage der wirtschaftlichkeit noch mal
ganz neu stellt aber das ist ja
wahrscheinlich dann doch eher ein
langfristiges unterfangen weil sich
viele probleme gibt bahnstrecken die
eine andere breite der gleise haben als
in europa und so weiter und so fort also
muss ja jetzt erst mal in dieser
getreide saison sozusagen das getreide
doch wahrscheinlich woanders herkommen
wo er ja wir sehen andere an zusätzlich
gehungert wir sind gar nicht so schlecht
bei den alternativ routen von den fünf
millionen tonnen dies durchschnittlich
waren über das schwarze meer vor dem
krieg sind wir jetzt bei 1,7 millionen
tonnen nebenbei gelandet die jüngsten
zahlen die ich jetzt heute bekommen habe
von meinem ukrainischen kollegen gehen
davon aus dass sie noch mal dass erhöhen
können richtung 2 millionen tonnen das
ist schon allerhand aber es gibt zwei
probleme bekommt logistisch an die
grenzen das problem dass sie
angesprochen haben die verfügbarkeit von
waggons ist auch ein problem in europa
neue zu bauen dauert jahre die
verfügbarkeit von lkws massives problem
und wir haben noch ein problem die
preise gehen natürlich hoch für das
verladen in rumänien übrigens preise die
dann auch die rumänischen bauern
bezahlen müssen die finden es nicht so
toll und innerhalb der ukraine haben
einen preisverfall bei getreide das
heißt es rechnet sich für viele
ukrainischen bauern auch nicht mehr die
überlegen sich jetzt umzusteigen auf
andere produkte also von daher die
ukraine braucht eine perspektive eine
andere route jetzt kurzfristig helfen
wir so viel wie möglich raus zu bekommen
aber auf dauer braucht der alternativ
route zum schwarzen meer und wir müssen
einander mehr weizen anbauen also sind
sie da nicht vielleicht jetzt dann auch
in einer ähnlichen situation wie ihr
kollege habe möglicherweise dinge tun zu
müssen die man nicht gerne tut als
grüner also er greift zur kohle reserve
und sie werden vielleicht auch
flächenstilllegungen für biodiversität
verzichten müssen na ja das tue ich ja
ich habe vorgeschlagen bei der
kommission dass wir ausnahmsweise mit
der neuen gab die 2023 gilt also die
neue gemeinsame agrarpolitik
darf man weiß noch weizen nicht mehr
anbauen das ist die frage der
fruchtfolge die eigentliche ökologisch
sehr sinnvoll ist damit die böden sich
erholen können ich habe eure beantragt
dass man ausnahmsweise weil's nur für
heizen anbauen kann damit wir die menge
kurzfristig erhöhen können trotzdem
halte ich es für falsch so wie wir jetzt
mal nicht erwarten von der union dass
man jetzt die fehler von gestern
wiederholt und die biodiversität den
kampf gegen die klimakrise einfach weg
schiebt deshalb habe ich gesagt die
besonders empfindlichen flächen die
vielfalt flächen die müssen wir schützen
ich habe sie freigegeben für
futtermittel aber ich habe es nicht
vollständig freigegeben so rate ich dazu
dass man jede einzelne entscheidung
abwägt jedes korn umdreht wenn sie so
wollen und dann versucht eine
angemessene antwort zu finden aber wo
ich aber waren möchte ist dass man
vergisst dass der hunger in der welt ja
vor allem von der klimakrise auch
ausgelöst wurde maßnahmen die diese
klimakrise verschärfen die können nicht
schlau sein langfristig ganz sicherlich
nicht aber jetzt geht's erst mal darum
im wahrsten sinne des wortes die teller
voll zu kriegen und zu verhindern dass
in den nächsten monaten menschen
verhungern müsste man dann nicht erst
mal ja auch andere überlegungen
beiseiteschieben und anbauen anbauen
anbauen und wirklich extensiv auch
felder nutzen so wie man es dann
vielleicht biologisch ökologisch korrekt
nicht machen wollte das ist ja richtig
aber dann lassen sie uns mal bitte über
flächen reden dann lassen sie über den
flächenfraß reden der ungehindert weiter
geht in deutschland sogar wieder
zugenommen lassen sie uns mal reden über
den autobahnbau wir haben eines der
dichtesten straßennetze der gesamten
welt bauen immer noch wie die
weltmeister da geht wertvolle fläche
verloren lassen sie uns mal darüber
reden ob es wirklich sinnvoll ist wir
haben ja eine alternative zum
verbrennungsmotor der es längst erfunden
die elektromobilität warum müssen wir
immer noch bei mission
flächen die wir nutzen können für die
menschliche ernährung wenn mein modell
sich durchsetzte reform der tierhaltung
für das sich ja gerade werben dann
kriegen wir ebenfalls flächen die wir
nutzen können von futtermitteln künftig
für die menschliche ernährung also man
kann da schon eine menge tun ich finde
es nur ganz spannend dass manchen
kollegen immer gerade das einfällt was
der natur besonders großen schaden
zufügt das was sie dagegen viel fläche
bringt das wollen sie nicht anrühren
nachtigall ick hör dir trapsen sagt
landwirtschaftsminister und
vielen dank wiedersehen
das haben wir vor einer stunde
aufgezeichnet zu putins krieg und den
folgen für die welt finden sie viele
videos und hintergründe bei uns
natürlich auch online auf zdf heute
zu anfang der sendung hatte ich schon
darauf hingewiesen der bundestag hat
heute die rechtslage im zusammenhang mit
schwangerschafts abbrüche geändert und
mehr und inter drohen liga dazu jetzt
für die 1 ja es geht um das sogenannte
werbeverbot für schwangerschafts
abbrüche bisher festgeschrieben im
umstrittenen paragrafen 219 a
strafgesetzbuch
er wird gestrichen dafür hat der
bundestag heute mit großer mehrheit
gestimmt die fraktionen von union und
fdp stimmten dagegen
der bundestagsbeschluss sieht auch vor
dass die urteile die seit 1990 nach §
209 10 a ergangen sind aufgerufen werden
der bund beendet das bisherige angebot
der sogenannten bürger tests also der
anlasslosen corona schnell testungen ab
kommenden donnerstag muss man in der
regel drei euro pro test selbst zahlen
bei bestimmten gründen wie den besuch in
einer klinik oder einem pflegeheim soll
der test kostenlos bleiben die neue
regelung gab gesundheitsminister
lauterbach nach einer einigung mit
finanzminister lindner bekannt
die linke hat den erfolg ihren
bundesparteitag begonnen zum auftakt
rief die vorsitzende wissler ihre partei
zur einigkeit und einem geschlossenen
auftreten nach außen auf zuletzt hatte
die linke mit schlechten wahlergebnissen
und auch mit sexismus vorwürfen zu
kämpfen für morgen ist die wahl der
führungsspitze vorgesehen
nach dem verheerenden erdbeben in
afghanistan ist die zahl der toten auf
mindestens 1100 gestiegen am morgen
trafen zwar erste un hilfslieferungen
osten des landes ein vielen der
verwüsteten dörfer werden die menschen
aber weiter auf hilfe mehrere nachbeben
und starker regen behindern zudem die
rettungsarbeiten und unter den trümmern
tausende zerstörte häuser werden noch
viele opfer vermutet
in brüssel ist der eu gipfel zu ende
gegangen themen des letzten tages waren
unter anderem die hohen energiepreise
und die gasknappheit und das kannst du
stolz sagte es seien alle aktivitäten
unternommen worden um energie aus
anderen ländern als russland zu
importieren diese anstrengungen müsse
weiter beschleunigt werden
mit blick auf den kriegs verlaufen der
ukraine ergibt sich ein gemischtes bild
mancherorts wagen die ukraine neue
offensiven womöglich auch dank neuer
waffensysteme die der westen zuletzt
geliefert hat im don was allerdings hat
die ukrainische armee den kampf um die
belagerte stadt ciego de netz vorerst
aufgegeben nach wochenlangen extrem
blutigen und verlustreichen krieg haben
sich die ukrainischen truppen dort jetzt
erst mal zurück zu
weiter im süden in der region um kassel
wird weiter gekämpft die stadt ist von
den russen besetzt die ukraine hofft sie
zurückerobern zu können wenn sie über
entsprechende waffen verfügt unsere
reporterin katrin eigendorf ist dort an
der front wir sind den scirocco der
vordersten front linie in der region
person die russische armee ist nur ein
paar kilometer von hier entfernt andré
zeigt mir die stellung die sie hier seit
drei monaten halten in einem kleinen
stück wald zwischen feldern für ihre
kalaschnikow haben sie kaum ausreichend
munition und um auf die entfernten
stellungen der russen zu vorher nur ein
altes artilleriegeschütz von 1985
die situation wird immer kritischer der
feind zieht dort immer mehr technik und
soldaten zusammen aber bis jetzt halten
wir ziemlich gut durch alles wird gut
andré zeigt uns ein video von ihrem
letzten einsatz es zeigt wie
aussichtslos der kampf ist
die situation ändert sich komplett wenn
neue waffen zum einsatz kommen dann wird
sich hier sofort die ganze natur des
krieges verändern
die schützengräben wirken wie aus einem
alten kriegsfilm das ganze lager
improvisiert in der küche unter offenem
himmel sammeln sie die lebensmittel
einen teil davon haben sie selbst
mitgebracht
andré zeigt mir wo sie schutz finden
wenn die russische armee auf ihrer
stellung feuert ein schacht in dem sie
auch übernachten können
aus dem westen kommen nun erste moderne
waffen nach wochenlangem warten
alexander breitet die panzerabwehrwaffen
aus den usa und großbritannien auf dem
feld aus zeigt uns wie sie funktionieren
präzisionswaffen die nach meinung der
soldat um den krieg verändern könnten
denn obwohl die russen vielmehr
militärtechnik besitzen diese waffen
erlauben ihnen sehr gezielt gegen
angriffe zu starten
der feind hat probleme mit der präzision
sie machen einfach alles platt wie wir
gerade in der region lucca 1 und dann
jetzt gesehen wo die hauptkämpfe jetzt
stattfinden sie töten zivilisten
soldaten völlig egal
wie weit der krieg in den alltag in den
umliegenden dörfern vorgerückt ist
erleben wir auf unserer rückfahrt der
elfjährige andré und sein freund bagdad
haben mit ihrer freundin deiner einen
checkpoint übernommen und kontrollieren
die autos
wir sind die siebzehnte panzerbrigade
auch in unserer schule haben wir diese
brigade
ein spiel das sie sehr ernst nehmen mit
ihrem plastik gewähren wollen sie die
heimat verteidigen es sind sommerferien
in zeiten des krieges
und jetzt macht nochmal heinz wolf
weiter mit dem blick auf die deutsche
wirtschaft in diesem krieg ja auch
vielfältig betroffen ist die stimmung in
der deutschen wirtschaft hat sich laut
dem neuen ifo geschäftsklimaindex für
juni eingedrückt die erwartungen der
unternehmen fielen demnach deutlich
pessimistischer aus frank bethmann wie
sehen diese erwartungen aus naja wenig
rosig nimmt man die stimmung der manager
als maßstab spricht vieles dafür dass
die deutsche wirtschaft vor einem
schwachen zweiten halbjahr steht die
sorgenfalten vertiefen sich dabei fand
diese aktuelle befragung statt noch
bevor gestern die zweite warnstufe bei
der gasversorgung ausgerufen werden
musste was die aussichten zusätzlich
eintrüben dürfte der konjunkturelle
gegenwind bereits jetzt heftig nicht nur
die rekord hohe inflation belastet auch
die stark gestiegenen rohstoff und
energiepreise sowie die absehbar
steigenden leitzinsen die künftige
investitionen verteuert werden
insbesondere die chemische industrie
seien höchst beunruhigt heißt es ist sie
doch besonders abhängig vom gas trübe
stimmung auch beim einzelhandel
bestätigt ifo konjunkturexperte klaus
wohlrabe überall besteht die sorge dass
die verbraucher weniger geld in den
geschäften lassen weil die
energierechnung deutlich steigt der
schwache geschäftsklimaindex schott die
anleger aber nicht der dax kann zum
wochenschluss gut 200 punkte oder 1,6
prozent zulegen einige sprechen von
einer momentaufnahme andere verweisen
darauf dass die 40 börsennotierten
konzerne im dax trotz krisenstimmung in
diesem jahr nach ersten schätzungen so
viel verdienen werden wie nie zuvor man
wird man vielen dank
in berlin heute abend verleihung des
deutschen filmpreises insgesamt neun
auszeichnungen hat das drama lieber
thomas gewonnen darunter die goldene
lola für den besten spielfilm
die deutsche fußball nationalmannschaft
der frauen hat das letzte testspiel vor
der im juli beginnenden
europameisterschaft klar wir wollen
sieben zu null sieg gegen die schweiz
war klarer bühne vor knapp 6000
zuschauern die überragende spielerin und
erzielte drei tore deutsche mannschaft
wird mit einer gelungenen generalprobe
zur europameisterschaft in england
reisen
zweiter wettkampftag bei den finales in
berlin den deutschen meisterschaften in
14 sportarten eine der titel holte heute
im kugelstoßen vor dem brandenburger tor
ex weltmeister david storl
seinen zehnten deutschen meistertitel
sichert sich storl mit der saison
bestleistung von 20 metern 32 damit
bleibt er aber erneut klar unter der
norm für die wm im juli in den usa simon
beyer wird zweiter vor titelverteidiger
dennis lukas die beide nicht über 20
meter hinausgekommen
titelverteidiger lukas pause hat das
mehrkampffinale der turner vor philipp
herder und glenn trebing gewonnen nach
schwachem beginn verteidigt 1000 yards
weiter am barren seinen titel auch dank
des starken auftritts an seinem
paradegerät
auf der spree hat das kajak tour julia
hacke und jakob shop unter dem bild den
160 meter sprint gewonnen im finale
setzt sich der berliner shop der olympia
silber in tokio holte mit seiner
partnerin aus lünen hauchdünn gegen das
duo pauline paszek und max lemke durch
sportgymnastin daria war voller wave ist
zum ersten mal deutsche meisterin im
mehrkampf die 15-jährige sieg vor
titelverteidigerin margarita kolosov war
von wave hatte am wochenende in israel
für die ersten deutschen em medaillen
seit 42 jahren gesorgt
das berlin der 20er jahre ein mythos die
deutsche hauptstadt galt als besonders
liberal und fortschrittlich
oft ist ja auch vom tanz auf dem vulkan
die rede in dieser nachkriegszeit die
zugleich eine vorkriegszeit war was
gleich weniger präsent ist im rückblick
wie brutal ist dort oft zu gehen wie
viele attentate und morde es gab gerade
am anfang der weimarer republik vor
allem auf das konto einer rechtsextremen
terror organisation in eine ganze serie
politischer mord der wohl folgenreichste
geschah heute vor 100 jahren walther
rathenau außenminister und eine der
mutigsten kämpfer für die junge deutsche
demokratie wurde erschossen daran
erinnert christian kirsch
es geschah hier heute vor 100 jahren
berlin grunewald königsallee attentat
auf den außenminister des deutschen
reiches rathenow war unterwegs zum
ministerium im offenen wagen
maschinenpistole handgranate eine art
hinrichtung der minister hatte
personenschutz abgelehnt als hätte er
sich dem ort drang der radikalen rechten
ergeben markus meckel war auch mal
deutscher außenminister der erste 1990
frei gewählte der ddr er weiß um die
gefährdung der demokratie durch
politischen extremismus rathenau sagte
er stand aufrecht für die junge
demokratie nämlich war es 1990 nicht
gefährlich für weitere war es täglich
wieviel diejenigen die eben versucht mit
demokratie wirklich zu etablieren
die beim europa league ist daran
gescheitert dass es zu wenig demokraten
gab und dieser mord war ein
antidemokratischer markt von rechts und
er jagt schockwellen durch die schwache
weimarer republik hunderttausende
protestieren allein in berlin gegen das
attentat auf den vor allem von der
extremen rechten verhassten juden raten
aua und die linke verachtet rathenow den
industriellen sohn den kapitalisten ein
vielschichtiger geist philosoph
unternehmer ingenieur künstler physiker
diplomat
der journalist thomas hügli sieht in
rathenow eine der zentralen figuren des
katastrophen reichen deutschen
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts der historiker
sebastian haffner hat er mal gesagt dass
hitler und rathenau die beiden
charismatischen politiker der weimarer
republik war hitler wegen seiner
unfassbaren gemeinheit rathenower wegen
seiner unfassbaren kultiviertheit
wäre rate noch nicht gestorben hätte die
deutsche geschichte einen anderen
verlauf genommen so aber lagert und
aufgebaut im reichstag und die republik
blieb im fadenkreuz
rathenau warum zeitgemäß den dingen wohl
voraus visionär was er 1913 schreibt
klingt nach eu verschmilzt die
wirtschaft europa zur gemeinschaft und
das wird früher geschehen als wir denken
so verschmilzt auch die politik das ist
nicht der weltfrieden aber es ist
milderung der konflikte kraft ersparnis
und solidarische zivilisation
millionen trauerten um ihn ein
bürgerliches bollwerk gegen
nationalistischen extremismus ich denke
es ist wichtig dass wir gerade die
abwahl der gewalt von rechts auch heute
wieder enden nachdem wir die erfahrung
machen müssen dass heute der feind
unserer demokratie rechtsstaat und
deshalb ist es richtig diesen mann in
erinnerung zu halten ein standhafter
demokrat einer zwischen fast allen
stühlen jetzt liegt ihr hier im südosten
berlins
seit 100 jahren
das hat man uns im heute journal um
23.45 meldet sich denn christopher
wehrmann mit unserem heutigen update und
wer die heute-show vermisst kann sich
jetzt trösten mit dem festival comedy
for future aus dem berliner
schillertheater leben wieder sinn
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend faszinierend war die zweiteilung
des wetters heute mittag wie wir hier
auf dem satellitenbild sehen nordöstlich
der elbe gab es keine wolke eine
trockene hitze 33 grad tageshöchstwerte
in berlin und auch in kirchdorf auf poel
das ist eine kleine ostseeinsel und
diese temperaturen waren dort nur wegen
einem ablandigen wind möglich im rest
des landes war neben viele wolken
unterwegs mit vielen gewittern in
hamburg zum beispiel hannover stuttgart
und münchen da hat es überall schon mal
gedonnert und geblitzt was passiert
jetzt es gab eben dieses tief bei den
britischen inseln das verlagert die
gewitter aktivität jetzt in der nacht
immer weiter in richtung osten und in
der zweiten nachthälfte also nach
mitternacht besteht die gefahr vor allem
noch im osten bayerns vor starkregen
also lokal vollgelaufenen kellern und
überflutungen vereinzelt sind auch hagel
und sturmböen mit dabei auch norden sind
immer mal noch gewittrige schauer
unterwegs insgesamt nimmt die gewitter
aktivität jetzt heute nacht von westen
her aber deutlich ab die nacht bleibt
mild mit 10 bis 18 grad immer noch
morgen früh an oder und neiße morgen
wird dann wieder überall sommerlich mit
23 bis 30 grad in der altmark die küste
es davon mal wieder nicht ausgenommen
wir auch schon heute wir haben die reste
der gewitter luft noch im osten
vereinzelt ist auch starkregen noch mal
mit dabei ansonsten gibt es
wetterberuhigung mit teils viel sonne
vor allem im südwesten ab sonntag wird
es dann im osten des landes wieder
richtig heiß von westen kündigen sich
aber immer wieder neue gewitter an die
vor allem am montag auch unwetterartig
ausfallen können auf wiedersehen